يقول مسؤولو البيت الأبيض إن الرئيس
بايدن في مزاج جيد للغاية
ومشغول في عزلة لأنه يعاني من
عدوى 19 ، ولكن وفقًا
لطبيب الرئيس ، فإنه يتناول
أدوية إضافية
لدرجة حرارته وسعاله في وقت سابق ، تحدثنا
مع كبير المستشارين الطبيين لبايدن الدكتور
أنطوني.  fauci الذي قال إنه على الرغم من أن
الرئيس يستخدم جهاز الاستنشاق ، فإن
بايدن لا يواجه أي مشكلة في التنفس ، إلا أنه يعاني من
عدوى في الجهاز التنفسي العلوي في
الوقت الحالي ، وهو يعاني من سيلان في الأنف
، ولديه تاريخ من الإصابة
بنزلات برد لا علاقة
لها بفيروس كورونا.  لديه تاريخ من الإصابة
بالربو ويستخدم موسع قصبي
للتأكد من أنه يتنفس جيدًا ، ولا
يواجه صعوبة في التنفس على الإطلاق في الوقت الحالي ،
وأعتقد أن هذا سيكون تفسيرًا خاطئًا
للقول إن هذا شيء
يفعله بانتظام عندما يصاب
بعدوى الجهاز التنفسي العلوي
يستمر الرئيس في التحسن ولدينا
سبب للاعتقاد بأنه سيقدم أداءً جيدًا للغاية
للأسباب الواضحة التي تم تطعيمه بها
د  يضاعف من تعاطيه على عقار مضاد للفيروسات
له سجل جيد للغاية في
منع الناس من التقدم إلى
مرض خطير ، لذا فهو يعمل بشكل جيد
للغاية ويستمر في تحسين
الدكتور فوشي ، كما ناقش ما إذا كان مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
بحاجة إلى تغيير توصيته إلى
عزل أطول  فترة استمع إليها
الأشخاص لديهم ظروف مختلفة في
حياتهم وقد يكون من الصعب جدًا في
بعض الأحيان أن يتمكن الأشخاص
من الاستمرار في الاختبار قبل أن يتمكنوا من العودة
أو الخروج لمدة 10 أيام بأكملها
حيث يحتاج بعض الأشخاص إلى ارتداء قناع
والعودة إلى العمل بسبب
وضعهم الاجتماعي أو الاقتصادي ، لذا
فهو حقًا عدم تجانس
للظروف وعليك حقًا أن تمر
بالظروف التي تكون
فيها في منصب الرئيس لتكون قادرًا على
الاختبار كل يوم والانتظار حتى  يصبح
سلبيًا قبل أن يعود ، لكن هذا
لا يعني أن على الجميع فعل
ذلك